look I get it I'm only a few clefairy
candies away from being able to make a
super-tough clefable and the temptation
to become the very best is strong that
said last week I took a few hours out
from Pokemon go to play inside and i'm
really glad i did because it might be my
favorite game of twenty sixteen so far
here's why
I expected to like inside actually I
expected to love inside which usually
Prime's me perfectly to be severely
disappointed much like I was with
unravel and child of light but inside is
something else play dad's last claim to
fame was six years ago with the
critically acclaimed limbo both games
center around physics-based puzzle
solving but with so few ways to interact
with the world walking jumping and
grabbing essentially you'd expect the
puzzles to be overly simplistic but they
aren't insights puzzles are certainly
easier than Limbo's but it still nails
the balance of giving players a
challenge without grinding the feeling
of urgency to a halt while you figure
out what on earth you're supposed to do
next many of the puzzles are just common
sense the next logical move through the
room or the safest route to keep your
squishy little protagonist intact that
in nowhere makes them simple but it
makes the puzzles make sense within the
world of the game I've been a big fan of
puzzle games since I was a kid and I've
always found logical solutions to be the
most satisfying and in the case of
inside the most sensible as the
objective is always to move forward of
course you can only ever move forward
well occasionally backwards but mostly
forward what I'm trying to clumsily get
at is the fact that inside is a 2d
side-scroller well they're one of my
favorite things about the game is how
effectively play dead have built a 3d
world in a 2d side-scroller often I'd
hit the up arrow key expecting my little
dude to wander into the background
scenery inside doesn't ever make you
feel like you're in a restricted space
it uses respective and clever art
direction to make each of its
environments appear far bigger than what
is traversable it then immerses you by
instilling a combination of tension and
Terra through moments like running from
barking dogs through thick dark forests
hiding in the shadows to avoid getting
seen by masked men with torches and
tasers and holding your breath in
seemingly bottomless water while you try
to escape what lives within it your
struggle to survive the game world is
underpinned by empathy for your
protagonist and the curiosity of
wondering what you'll find if you just
keep moving forward although the world
is so big and layered inside never feels
the need to explain itself just like
limbo you wake up in a forest and you're
expected to
had a walk jump grab and push on your
own you're also being pursued by things
that want to kill you so the motivation
to work that [ __ ] out fast is strong in
months the same way the story unravels
with very little contextualization and
you probably won't be able to start
piecing together even a semblance of
what's happened until the end let alone
who the bad guys are and while you're
there at all there's no dialogue no
narration they're particularly friendly
NPCs unless you count a horde of tiny
baby chickens and helpful fish and yet
while playing this game i experienced
relief extreme fear frustration and
quite a bit of schadenfreude there were
a number of moments that had me staring
awestruck at whatever was going on of
course I'm overly emotional but you'll
probably get some degree of each of
those turn inside is satisfying in the
way that making your way through any
puzzle game is satisfying but it's also
satisfying in the way that it stirs up
emotions as you play when I played
inside it felt like I was in a nightmare
much of the time in fact it's a bit like
eight different horror movies in one
you're incredibly vulnerable and spend
most of your time running hiding and
hoping you're faster than whatever's
trying to kill you and by god they will
kill you much like limbo the deaths of
inside a brutal and graphic inside wants
its world to fill you with read and
understand completely how nightmarish
it's grim dystopia is and it's really
quite effective at it like limbo inside
isn't explicit about its themes or
narrative which is why if you go ahead
and try and google inside the first
suggested result is meaning it's the
kind of game that's ripe for fan
theories and speculation and has you
thinking about it long after you're done
playing if you're a fan of games that
transport you some when you and embed
you in a rich dark world peppered with
satisfying puzzles and a mysterious
narrative inside is worth your time I
have a serious affection for games that
force you to remember them and inside
particularly in its final moments will
absolutely make you remember it
you